- OK, Kawhi, it’s the conference semifinals.
You can try to roll a 20 to hit an off-balance buzzer-beater over Embiid...
- No way! That’s impossible!
Roll a one to 15, and we can regroup in overtime.
- Don’t listen to Gasol. Take the play off for load management!
- Guys, I got this.
It's all part of the game.
- Yes!
- Victory!
- We won!
Embiid's crying, and we won!
- Hey, guys.
Can I play?
- No, Pau.
He refuses to retire.
- Charge! Charge!
Foul on you!
- Hey, Drake...
is Kawhi home?
- No.
My boy never came home last night,
and I think he's trying to send me a message through the Canada Day lights.
What is he trying to tell us?
I can't crack the code.
- Don't worry, Drake.
We'll find him.
- You should check the Sports Science Lab on the outskirts of town.
I'd go myself, but I was banned for giving Nick Nurse a shoulder rub.
- How are we going to get in?
- Easy.
The lab is defended by the Washington Wizards.
If you get past Bradley Beal,
there's zero help.
- Three-on-one! Three-on-one!
Little help?
- Hey.
Wait.
Stop.
- Thank God everything in this town is a short bike ride apart.
Now let's fan out and find Kawhi!
- You won't find him here.
It's too late!
- Doctor Rivers?!
- I bleed Raptors red.
- Thanks, VanVleet.
- You can call me Twenty-three.
Kawhi went through that portal.
- The Upside Down!
- Well, technically, the Jay Bilas Tremendous Upside Down.
- Dios mío!
The Upside Down is even worse than I imagined.
- I think this is just downtown Los Angeles.
- There's Kawhi!
- And Danny Green!
- We don’t care about him!
Kawhi!
- The Demo-George-an!
- But seriously, Kawhi can’t go back.
I blew up my old team to play with him.
- He's right.
Sorry, guys, I’m staying here.
- What? We won a campaign together!
Don’t you realize how rare that is in Toronto?
And what’s so special about this guy?
Well, when healthy, he’s an excellent two-way Demo-George-an.
- But Kawhi, we had a historic run.
C’mon...
don’t you want to defend our title?
- No.
It’s 70 degrees and sunny here,
I’m tired of children's games,
and most of all...
I just don't want to play with you guys anymore.
- Fine.
We don't need you anyway!
We’re still a respectable two seed.
All right, Pascal, it’s Game 7 of the conference semifinals.
You need to roll a 15 or a 10 to send it into overtime.
- Outcome unclear.
But Pascal kicked Daniel Theis in the face!
- No, I am the real Chris Paul.
You want the real deal,
especially when it comes to home and auto insurance.